all right well maybe you want to fly
away to somewhere cooler in Las Vegas is
about to become a hub for training
airport security today TSA just opened
its newest Academy right here in the
valley 8 news now reporter Brian will
explains what this means for air travel
and for what it means for Las Vegas
being here allows us to bring officers
from the central part of the country
from the western part of the country
into a airport environment to conduct
their initial training TSA Academy West
now a second facility to train officers
with TSA Academy East located south of
Savannah Georgia Las Vegas plays a
crucial role in Aviation Security we
have our Innovation checkpoint for the
entire agency is here in Las Vegas
that's where we test out our newest
technology that will eventually see its
implementation throughout airports in
the United States saw 430 airports this
state-of-the-art 26 000 square foot
facility features six classrooms two
large multi-purpose rooms and virtual
instruction space once hired a new TSA
officer will conduct training at their
home airport and then be sent to one of
two of the academies for two weeks of
on-site training that training includes
pat down techniques screening of
personal property customer experience
audience and x-ray detection
capabilities what we do is critically
important for our national security is
critically important for everybody else
in the transportation system the academy
has the capacity to train 180 officers
in person from around the country each
week it employs 40 full-time instructors
and staff near Reed International Brian
will 8 News Now